[Music]
uh hey well look I'm so glad that this
album is actually here because I you
know it felt like one of these like
methodical albums that we always hear
about and then it never ends up coming
out yeah how hard was it to get
everybody to like you know this one's
coming out this ain't none of that this
is this is for real for real for real
for real I was hoping it wasn't like
detox 2.0 timing thing man like we we
had many opportunities to pull the
trigger but it was like should we right
and we discussed it as like you know for
intelligent Minds you know pow-wowing
and we like what's that date that date
could have been October 2020 you could
have dropped that album we could have
dropped all of last year anytime earlier
this year and we just we just felt like
let's do some things like get all the
merch together get all the ducks in row
get you know and we did an nft play
um
which um
um you know once we put it out on the
nft
um we had to wait a certain amount of
time before we can actually put a
different record out on the street this
is a different record than than the nft
uh some of the songs are the same but a
few most of these are new how lucrative
is the nft play is that I mean because a
lot of artists are going that direction
I mean Snoop pulled doggy style and all
the death row stuff off of dsps like
you know it's a thing where it was great
for us
um because we you know got a great deal
uh but you know the nft market the whole
crypto Market has been like going
backwards ever since like Mother's Day
so yeah it's been bad so it just was not
great timing for the group but it was
lucrative for the group so you know in a
lot of ways it worked in a lot of ways
if we did it when it was a bull market
instead of a bear market then it would
have did a lot better right you know uh
we always plan to make sure it hit the
street though uh you know that was uh
that was a you know one of our demands
that yeah we can do this nft play but at
some point this music gotta hit all
platforms you know CDs we making albums
we doing everything you can do
um to get this to the streets and
December 9th is the date yeah Friday